[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue en sardaigne
[Musique]
on dirait une piscine transparent c'est
vraiment vraiment magnifique
[Musique]
on est parti quelques jours en sardaigne
en vacances et c'est un endroit qui est
juste extraordinaire les ans aux
antilles c'est naturel on est dans son
coin comme vous le voyez sur la vidéo
c'est extrêmement sauvage
il n'y a pas de grandes barres
d'immeubles pas de grandes tours
d'immeubles c'est vraiment préserver et
ça c'est juste hyper appréciable si vous
voulez partir en sardaigne
j'avais en gros deux grandes solutions
soit vous prenez une une location comme
nous on affirme étaient partis déjà il
ya il ya deux ans dans une dans un hôtel
qui était super héros link lviv c'était
vraiment un truc génial
généralement on est en en tout cas quand
on est en tout inclus parce que parce
qu'il faut savoir qu'à côté vous invite
pas grand chose vous n'avez pas de grand
tourisme de masse avec des grandes zones
de construction des grands hôtels des
grandes choses comme ça comment on peut
trouver dans le sud de la france
là vous avez des hôtels à des endroits
bien spécifique peut-être en se
rapprochant d'olbia
de l'autre côté mais je suis même pas
sûr on était déjà plus au nord vers
saint théodore ou ya quelques années et
son l'avais pas vu là on est sur la
costa smeralda c'est-à-dire quelques
kilomètres en dessous d'olbia
et c'est hyper naturel hyper préserver
en dessous il ya un énorme tel un grand
4 étoiles avec piscine tennis
enfin un truc monstrueux comme comme on
trouve assez fréquemment
et pourtant des formules sont en tout
inclus parce que si vous voulez trouver
une pizzeria dont vous avez intérêt trop
dessus sinon les commerces est loin faut
prendre la voiture et la plupart du
temps les gens ici n'ont pas de voiture
alors nous on avait trop d'attenté du
coup celle aventure on n'a pas de
voiture et on a fait le choix de de tout
faire à pied
alors bon ça se fait ça c'est par contre
on fait les courses sous quasiment 40
degrés on crame la sage et vous qu'est
ce pack
[Musique]
faire des réservations alors que t'as
pas de bagnole y aller par 40 des vins
tous les deux jours pour aller sur six
pack de six bouteilles d'eau pardon
parce que l'eau est pas beau d'hab c'est
cool mais c'est chaud
[Musique]
navette gratuite ça c'est vraiment
génial
on a des navettes qui nous emmène donc
ils viennent vous chercher ici là on est
apte à nous on est là pour aller jusqu'à
budo ni la grande ville à côté puis
enfin dessert d'autres endroits de
village il ya cinq passages par jour le
premier c'est un 8 heures et qu'elle du
matin le plus tard ça 1h30 du matin ça
vous permet quand même d'avoir une
grande plutôt doré pour pouvoir vous
balader alors bon il ya cinq passages
uniquement mais on peut quand même mais
on peut quand même et ça vraiment
vraiment plaisir
d'ailleurs l'autre jour on est partis
abus donnez en bus
[Musique]
non
je
bien
[Musique]
on a mangé dans un restaurant qui était
super les gens étaient très gentils
on a voulu comme en attaque si pour
revenir ce qu'on était un peu en dehors
des horaires du bus puis bon par rapport
à nos petites y avoir quatre ans c'était
compliqué et bien pas de taxis pas de
disponibilité avant un bon moment
c'est la responsable du resto qui a
demandé à qui a demandé à son employé de
nous ramener chez nous à fait pas 5 6
kilomètres j'étais dingue on était au
restaurant il ya les maxi parra qui
travaille au restaurant a accepté de
nous ramener gentiment et sa enfants
c'est pas possible
donc merci beaucoup ça va du coup elle
se retrouvait à deux chars le service et
puis nouma nous ont ramenés à domicile
c'était vraiment gentil les gens sont
gentils sont serviables ci peut vous
aider le feront et ça s'est super bien
la serbe est ça qui est cool ça fait la
deuxième fois je vous dis qu on vient on
trouve vraiment que les gens sont
gentils le spot est super parce qu'il ya
des grandes étendues naturelles
on a vraiment des descoings qui sont
hyper préserver vous avez l'hôtellerie
kg et hop nous la location elle est
vraiment sympa puis les gens qui nous
loue son super serviable très très très
gentil voilà on s'éclate et surtout
c'est pas cher vous allez au restaurant
une pizza c'est 7 euros 7 euros 50 8
euros et 9 euros la plus chère aux
prenons une taille de du rosé ou un
rouge qui est franchement et bien c'est
du vin local mais qui est très sympa
vous en tirez pour 15 16 euros le plat
de pâtes pareil c'est pas cher c'est pas
cher ça c'est vraiment agréable
[Musique]
et
le petit loquet s'y passe à vinh hiên
qu'ils vivent
normal que l'accord est également très
attendue puisqu'elle est longtemps
passée les antilles facile d'alien le
spread idiote les pâtes traditionnelles
armes traditionnelles sans moi la
musique
[Musique]
franchement on peut le dire la sardaigne
c'est beau c'est préserver les gens sont
gentils c'est pas cher un seul conseil à
vous donner
allez-y vous ferez des nouvelles
il ya énormément d'allier 10,6 et leur
baignoire
[Musique]
m